Islamic terrorists in sri lanka murder
290 Catholics on Easter Sunday and
around the world churches have become
the number one target for attacks so
political and media elites who don't
want to admit that fact have made up a
new term to describe all of them we will
explore lies and ignorance in our post
Christian society
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Noel's show
[Music]
hello there fellow Easter worshipers and
non Easter worshipers Passover
worshipers maybe some Ramadan worshipers
out there I want to have all of those
worshipers in here to analyze the new
way that left-wingers media elites want
to deny that Christians are being
victimized around the world welcome
welcome welcome we will get to all of
that in a second but first rings mission
is to make neighborhoods safer you might
already know about there's smart video
doorbells and cameras that protect
millions of people everywhere ring helps
you stay connected to your home anywhere
in the world so if there's a package
delivery or a surprise visitor you will
get an alert and be able to see hear and
speak to them all from your phone that's
thanks to the HD video and two-way audio
features on ring devices I love ring it
makes me feel safer I give ring out to
my friends it's a perfect housewarming
gift everybody at daily wire loves a
ring including our senior producer Jay
hey who fortunately I've never had some
wacko come up to my house in the night I
feel safe being protected but I've never
had to deal with it one on one the other
day
Jay hey gets woken up at 3 in the
morning because two wacko drug addicts
ring his doorbell
he picks up from his bed on his phone
because he's got ring and he talks to
him he says what do you want they say oh
uh nothing we and then they scram why
they were trying to see if anybody was
home he was able to talk to them scare
him right away that video is uploaded to
the cloud he could have been doing that
from the office he could have done it
from a beach it doesn't matter with a
ring you are always on top of your home
security as a listener we have a special
offer on a ring starter kit available
right now with a video doorbell and
motion activated floodlight camera the
starter kit has everything you need to
start building a ring of security around
your home do it you will feel safer it
is extraordinarily inexpensive for the
value that you're getting go to ring.com
slash Knolls
KO wles that is ring.com slash Knolls
kenda wles islamic terrorists murdered
290 people in Sri Lanka this was mostly
in a Catholic Church also at
some hotels that were frequented by by
tourists who were in town for Easter the
group that we now think has committed
this crime is the national thumb leaf
JAMA earth this is a radical Islamic
group and it's not really being reported
very much by the mainstream media
they're saying we don't know we have to
wait we're not certain who this is now
finally it does seem that it's this
radical Imam that was behind this attack
it's this Islamic group that's behind it
and so now the media are pivoting Daily
Beast put out a headline they said quote
is Sri Lanka Easter Massacre a bid to
revive global holy war this is the
response that the left so often gives to
Islamic terrorist attacks Barack Obama
used to give this response they'd say
listen the most important thing we can
do right now is not identify the fact
that Islamic terrorists committed the
attack why because that's just what the
terrorists want this is what they would
always say they'd say listen the if
Islamic terrorists commit a terror
attack the most important thing don't
don't associate the attack with Islam
there they might want a global holy war
we can't allow them to get what they
want with a global holy war at a certain
point they're waging the war that this
is the thing with war is that your
opponent has a say you're not the only
person who can say well I'm going to be
at war where I'm not going to be at war
this is how the left tried to frame 9/11
they said we launched a war into
Afghanistan we launched a war into Iraq
no we didn't
terrorists waged a war on us when they
knocked down our twin towers and when
they hit the Pentagon they declared the
war so you can have two options at that
point you can either put your head in
the sand
surrender pretend that nothing's
happening or you can fight those are
your two options but you don't get a say
over whether or not you're in a war when
someone wages a war on you you're in a
war and
there is an explicitly holy aspect to
this war sayo is is this just an attempt
to revive a global holy war no it is a
global holy war this is explicitly an
attack on Christians and on Christianity
it happened on Easter Sunday when that
Cathedral of notre-dame burned down on
the first day of Holy Week said you know
this timing is a little strange although
we don't know we actually don't know
what caused that Cathedral fire this
happened on Easter Sunday 290 Christians
specifically Catholics attacked three
churches and hotels on the holiest day
in the Christian calendar holier than
Christmas Christians are highly
persecuted minority in Srilanka
Christians make up 7.4%
of the population of Sri Lanka and it's
not just in Sri Lanka around the world
churches have become the number one
target for attacks right now around the
world more than three churches are
attacked per day there's an average of
105 Church attacks per month almost all
of which are ignored by the mainstream
media obviously the Nutri dom burning is
the is the most explicit example and
again we don't know what caused that
fire yet we don't know one way or the
other I think a lot of people are trying
to say well it was just some accident
move on we don't know is just just an
accident we have no idea what caused
that fire for sure there are also many
many desecrations and burnings of
churches all around france that were
going on all during the week prior to
the burning of note read on all of those
other church attacks desecrations
smearing excrement all over the church
burning churches down days after the
notre-dame attack there was an American
professor who walked into Saint
Patrick's Cathedral in New York with two
gallons of gasoline and lighters and
when he was finally arrested he said oh
I was gonna bring these to my car that's
you you were going to your did you park
in st. Patrick's Cathedral what were you
doing obviously another attempt to burn
down a major Cathedral the
most important cathedral in the United
States that same guy had booked a ticket
to Rome later that day I guess he
thought he'd burned down st. Pat's fly
over to Rome and I don't know try to
burn down st. Peter's or something
yesterday also on Easter Sunday a woman
jumped onstage at an Easter service
holding a baby and a handgun screaming
about how she's gonna blow up the church
fortunately she was tackled think the
baby is okay and nobody was injured
during that attack Christians are the
most persecuted religious group in the
world that's the conclusion of all of
this that's not hyperbole that's not
some shocking statement that's according
to the Pew Research Center the Pew
Research Center last year came out with
a study analyzing trends all the way up
to 2016
it showed that Christians are the most
persecuted religious group in the world
they are harassed by law often in 144
countries that's up from 128 countries
the year before that edges at Muslims
who are also harassed in a lot of
countries but not as many as the
Christians are and yet if you went out
to someone on the street right now and
you said Christians are the most
persecuted religious group in the world
what would happen they would laugh in
your face you hear this all the time if
you write on a column or on Twitter or
something I hear this all the time
they'll say oh yes Christians are so
persecuted oh yeah Wow after the
Christians actually they are at my
church in New York
the Church of st. Michael there they
finally dedicated a shrine to persecuted
Christians in the Middle East because
that story was totally untold nobody had
talked about the Christian persecution
that's been going on for years and years
and years even when we look at our
immigration policies in the United
States under Barack Obama we took in
scores and scores hordes untold numbers
of Muslim refugees from war-torn
countries like Syria we took in barely
any Christians but Syria today is a
Muslim nation why weren't we taking in
the most persecuted minorities why
weren't we taking in Christians the the
the reason for this is because a
post-christian society which is what we
now are
has two problems the society both does
not understand Christianity and it
thinks it does understand Christianity
it's like that line from remark twain
who says it's not what you don't know
that gets you into trouble but what you
know for sure that just ain't so we
don't even know in the united states
that we're a post christian society we
don't even know in the West that we are
a post Christian society what do I mean
by that do I mean that Christianity is
over no it's not over
Christianity will endure until the end
of the age the church will always be
with us but the period in which
Christianity was the dominant cultural
institution where virtually everybody
went to church where the Christian view
of the world was the nearly exclusive
view of the world in the West that
period is over and we're watching it
come to an end right now it doesn't mean
that all of society is permanently over
it doesn't mean that there won't be a
Christian revival let's not forget
Christianity was was not born into a
Christian society let's not forget that
the beginning of Christianity which
we've just gone through on Good Friday
all the way through Easter Sunday was
Christ himself being crucified let's not
forget that Christians were persecuted
for all of the early history of the
church the martyrs were crucified upside
down were tortured and killed in
horrific ways then we had this nice
period of Christian society now we're in
a post Christian society how do I know
that we're in a post Christian society
because you're all just a bunch of
Easter worshippers
that's according to Hillary Clinton and
Barack Obama a new phrase yesterday
entered into the English language that
came by way of our political elites
Barack Obama and Hillary Clinton the
phrase is Easter worshippers Barack
Obama responding to the terror attacks
in Sri Lanka said the attacks on
tourists and Easter worshippers in Sri
Lanka are an attack on humanity on a day
devoted to love Redemption and renewal
we pray for the victims and stand with
the people of Sri Lanka
attack on tourists and Easter worshipers
does he mean Christians I think the word
that Barack Obama is looking for is
Christians specifically actually
Catholics and listen even the language
that he uses on a day devoted to love
Redemption and renewal we pray for the
victims and stand with the people of Sri
Lanka what the day is it is a day
devoted to love and redemption and
renewal because of the resurrection of
Christ there are other days devoted to
love and redemption and renewal Easter
Sunday is about the resurrection of
Christ people would always say actually
Chris Cuomo the Fredo of the Cuomo
family was just going off on this
because we've been pointing this out a
number of conservatives have pointed out
how ridiculous the phrase Easter
worshipers is when Barack Obama should
have used the phrase Christian and what
Chris Cuomo said is oh you guys are just
using code to say that Barack Obama
isn't one of us first of all we're not
using code it's not code when you
directly criticize somebody and you're
explicit about what you're criticizing
them for and we're not even saying
Barack Obama isn't one of us we're
saying he's not even the guy that he's
pretending that he is remember Barack
Obama ran I would go to church all the
time
he's a very professed patriot professed
Christian all of this all of these words
but then in his behavior and and in the
language that he uses after he gets
elected he it doesn't seem that way
Easter worshippers I've never heard that
phrase before have you ever heard that
phrase before Hillary Clinton said the
same thing on this holy weekend for many
faiths we must stand united against
hatred and violence I'm praying for
everyone affected by today's horrific
attacks on Easter worshippers and
travelers in sri lanka now Christians
not Catholics Easter worshippers a holy
weekend for many faiths you see it's not
Easter Sunday no no no it's the holy
weekend for many faiths and it was
actually
just but there was evil attacks that
that hurt people it was those evil
attacks it was just hate it was hatred
and violence
it wasn't Islamic militants waging war
on [ __ ] Christians as they prayed on
Easter Sunday
no no it was these broad terms Easter
worshipers that's all we can talk about
now Holy on castra had the same thing by
the way he said on a day of redemption
and hope these evil attacks on Easter
worshipers and tourists in Sri Lanka is
deeply saddening my prayers today are
with the dead and injured and their
families may we find grace this is so
strange why all of these responses say
Easter worshippers Hillary Clinton when
there are attacks on gay people she says
I stand with the LGBT community
she doesn't when Orlando gets hit she
doesn't say I stand with nightclub
dancers my heart goes out to nightclub
dancers no I stand with the LGBT
community when Muslims are attacked for
something she doesn't say I stand with
Ramadan worshippers I stand with hijab
wearers I know she says I stand with
Muslims but when it's Christians know
then we can't say that we're not allowed
to say that word Christian it sounds so
I'd sound so you know like accurate and
precise we're not allowed to use that
kind of language when we're talking
about our culture our civilization
Christians were not allowed to do that
we need this generic made-up term which
I don't think anybody had used until
last night Easter worshippers so why is
the left using using the phrase nobody
worships Easter we've never heard of
this phrase before we worship Christ we
are Christ's worshippers do you want to
use the word worshippers use the word
Christ why can't the left's a Christian
it's because Christians can't be victims
that Christians can't be victims not in
reality obviously in reality Christians
are the most persecuted religious group
in the world but in leftist ideology
Christians cannot be victims because of
all of their theories because of
intersectionality because
we know that at the top of the oppressor
pyramid is the straight white man who
knows that he is a man who is a
Christian that's the moat that's the
worst oppressor in the whole world so
when when that person is the victim he
can't be a Christian he has to be some
new phrase he has to be an Easter
worshipper in fairness to the phrase
Easter worshipper by the way there are
lots of people who only go to church on
Easter Sunday they're the ones who go on
Easter maybe they go on Christmas I
don't think that it's that this is the
reason why Barack Obama and Hillary
Clinton are using that phrase I don't
think that's what they're trying to
convey I think what they're trying to do
is defend their own ideologies but this
is true this is also a problem the
number of Americans who are members of a
church right now is that the lowest
number ever recorded you're gonna see a
lot of headlines that say American
church membership Falls to 80 year lows
it's gonna make you think that 80 years
ago there were also not a lot of people
going to church then it rose and then it
fell that's not true the reason that
were at 80 year lows right now is
because we only started looking at these
numbers 80 years ago so we are at
certainly historic lows all-time lows of
church membership in the United States
church membership in the u.s. held
steady at about 70 percent from 1938 to
1999 you had 61 years of it basically
around 70 percent maybe it goes up to 73
or even a little higher then it goes
down to 68 67 but it's around 70 percent
then around 1999 that number plummets to
50% the plummeting the the collapse of
church membership is by far most
pronounced among Democrats it's down 23%
in the last 20 years it's down from 71%
now down to 48% the majority of
Democrats do not belong to any church
and it's much less pronounced among
Republicans it's down only 8%
single-digit drop from about 70 percent
- I'm sorry down from about 76 percent
that's not
down from 75 percent to 69 percent
somewhere around there so it's as though
Republicans were punching above the
average before by two or three points
then there is still a drop much less
pronounced than among Democrats
why has church membership plummeted
there are a few theories on this the the
number one theory that's being pushed by
people who don't want to take an
explicitly cultural lens is that it's
the Internet here's the this is the idea
that all a pundit is is writing about it
hot hot air which is that basically
anything that happens starting in the
90s is explained by the internet and
this theory usually holds true however
in this case the church membership thing
is that it's part of a trend that began
earlier membership in civic institutions
in the United States dropped earlier
than the internet became popular and
then churches followed afterwards so
first you had people not going to the
PTA people not going to the Kiwanis Club
people not going to the Lions Club
whatever then you had people not going
to churches I think the actual culprit
here is most likely not the Internet I
don't think it explains I don't think
the internet theory explains why there
was such a difference in the way
Republicans and Democrats reacted to
this trend Republicans use the internet
just as much as Democrats do doesn't
explain why it follows earlier trends I
think the biggest issue here is
religious ignorance this is also known
as millennial theory the theory that as
people are raised totally ignorant of
religion they're not brought up really
as members of churches they're not
brought up with any real religious
education they're not brought up with
much education at all be that
philosophical or literary or historical
as a result of that religiosity plummets
you're not going to hear this from the
Atheist types on the internet what you
always hear from the mainstream media
the elites is as education increases
atheism also increases this isn't true
it's true in
narrow way because you can look at
credentialism you can look at people Oh
so-and-so has a degree from Harvard and
Harvard graduates are more likely to be
atheists therefore educated people are
more likely to be atheists the problem
isn't too much education it's too little
you've got this whole generation raised
without religion largely raised without
religion now you've got religiosity
declining if it's the Millennial theory
that's right if it's my theory that's
right if it's just that these
generations are being taught less and
less about religion it would explain why
it's most pronounced among Democrats
because Millennials are overwhelmingly
Democrats are almost 2 to 1
Democrats to Republicans the the New
Atheism movement highlighted this those
new atheists Christopher Hitchens Daniel
Dennett Richard Dawkins made terribly
weak arguments against religion totally
pathetic arguments but they were bought
by people who couldn't refute them
because they were basically biblically
illiterate you see this playing out in
the in the mainstream media
you see this playing out by people who
went to really good colleges really good
universities then they go and they work
for the New York Times and then they
expose their total ignorance
this headline came from The Associated
Press over the weekend quote tourist
mecca no true Daum also revered as place
of worship breaking news breaking news
no true DOM is a Cathedral some editor
at The Associated Press thought that it
was newsworthy that no true dom
cathedral is a place of worship and even
look at the language tourist mecca no
true dom also revered as a place of
worship wait until they find out that
tourist mecca mecca is also revered as a
place of worship wait until they find
out what the word mecca means which
refers to a holy city in the islamic
religion it's not just the associative
press that's religiously ignorant the
New York Times last week reported that
father jean-marc Fournier ran inside
notre Dom to retrieve a statue of Jesus
now the problem is there's no statue of
Jesus in Notre Dom and father jean-marc
Fournier didn't didn't run out carrying
some giant statue of Jesus on
is back it's because the the writer at
the New York time didn't didn't know
that the body of Christ that father
Fournier was referring to means the
Blessed Sacrament means the Eucharist
means the communion the host
he said I'm I I went in and I got the
body of Christ they thought everybody
right I guess that I don't know like a
big statue or something the body of
Christ is about as elemental to the
Christian faith as things get totally
ignorant in 2013 the New York Times
reported that Easter commemorates the
resurrection of Jesus into heaven think
about that for a second let that one
settle in if Jesus is resurrected into
heaven then he's not really resurrected
is he the resurrection means he comes
back to life in his body walks around in
a body on earth then he ascends into
heaven the the basic fact of
Christianity the resurrection totally
ignorant it's actually better what they
said the next year the next year 2014
the New York Times said that the Church
of the Holy Sepulcher Mark's quote the
site where many Christians believe Jesus
is buried let it sink in if you believe
that Jesus is buried somewhere chances
are you are not a Christian this
reporter this reporter who wrote that
has a master's degree from Cambridge
University one of the most ancient and
elite universities in the world and he's
apparently never read the New Testament
or if he has read the New Testament he
apparently missed the point
he missed the ending where Jesus stops
being buried and is resurrected he could
have talked to the reporter who reported
the previous year in 2005 the New York
Times was was talking about Pope John
Paul the second funeral Pope John Paul
the second was holding that staff that
bishops hold and that staff is called a
Crozier and he he had it in in his hand
and the New York Times referred to Pope
John Paul the second is holding a Crow's
a year like a little ear of a little
bird I guess he was holding a little
crows ear because they didn't
not only did they not know these aspects
of the Christian faith it didn't even
occur to them to ask now do you think
that the media would treat rule of Islam
in this sort of way do you think that
they would they would know they wouldn't
they would do their research they would
go in depth they would make sure that
they try to get it right but they treat
Christianity in a more flippant way
because that's the ideology and and also
I mean even broadly on all sorts of
religions these guys think okay oh
you're just some scared little people
who are afraid of the dark and need a
sky daddy to help you wake up in the
morning we are so sophisticated we are
so educated we are so elite we don't
need to concern ourselves with your
silly little fairy tales and as a result
they do not know the most basic elements
of the faith that shaped the entirety of
their civilization this is a major
problem
this calls for an obvious solution that
solution is that we must start teaching
the Bible in schools we'll explain why
in a second but first we got to think
about a Facebook in YouTube
if you're on Facebook and YouTube go to
daily wire com 10 bucks a month 100
dollars for an annual membership you get
me you get the Andrew Clavin show you
get the Ben Shapiro show you get the
Matt Walsh show you get to ask questions
in the mailbag coming up on Thursday get
your mailbag questions in you get to ask
questions backstage you get another
Kingdom and you get the leftist tears
tumblr mmm you know I'm gonna be going
to Cal State LA tomorrow I'll be giving
a speech on immigration on the wall
there's a good chance you're gonna need
your tumblr now the last time I gave a
speech at a university a bunch of wackos
screamed and how old the whole time and
then one of them squirted me with some
weird chemical I'm hoping nothing like
that happens tomorrow the president of
the university is already sending out
letters condemning offensive awful
speech so something tells me he's a
little worried about how his students
might
act check it out if you're in LA I love
to see you over there otherwise I hope
Feliz trimming it online in any case
make sure you get your tumbler go to
daily wire.com
we'll be right back
so if you write for the New York Times
you are allegedly highly educated right
you almost certainly went to Harvard or
some good university maybe you went to a
graduate school now you're right for
this elite publication probably went to
a top high school if you got into those
good colleges so you've had good
education basically your whole life
what's supposed to be good education and
yet you are biblically illiterate this
is a big deal the easy solution is to
teach the Bible in schools president
Trump has just endorsed this idea
president Trump came out a while ago
early this year in January and said it's
time to teach the Bible in schools
multiple states have bills on the table
right now endorsing this idea why is
that what all of them are pointing out
is that the Bible is integral to our
culture and our civilization now do I
want the Bible to be taught in schools
as though it's from one particular
perspective and this is the only way
that this can be interpreted and this is
the only way that you can read it
absolutely not why because the because
I'm a Catholic I'm a Catholic in a
country which has more Protestants than
Catholics so I I probably disagree
now that the difference here of course
is that there are lots of different
Protestant denominations all of which
disagree with one another about Bible
exegesis but that actually underscores
my point all of these Christians in
America maybe have a different take on
the Bible so I'm not saying that
everyone needs to have this only one
approach by the way in public schools no
other books are taught with only one
approach either
I think the boogieman argument events
against teaching the Bible in schools is
well then you're gonna get one
particular faith shove down people's
throats I don't think that's true when
you read Hamlet in an English class does
the teacher say this is the only way to
interpret it and every other way to
interpret it is wrong and if you don't
interpret it this way then you're going
to burn in hell forever no if you I'm
gonna give you an F if you don't
interpret it this way hopefully not no
however the
was the most important book ever written
the Bible is at the basis of all of our
culture all of our civilization this
year no public school student will read
the Bible in school today
all of those public school students will
celebrate Earth Day none of them will
read the Bible the most important book
ever written undergirds our entire
civilization all of them will celebrate
some ridiculous made-up pagan nonsense
that was invented by some weirdo who
ended up murdering and composting his
girlfriend
no one reads the Bible in school
everybody celebrates Earth Day he did he
did end up murdering and composting his
girlfriend this guy the guy who started
Earth Day IRA Einhorn invented Earth Day
in 1970 he then seven years later
murdered and composted his girlfriend
I'm not drawing a direct connection
between the two I'm pointing out that
Earth Day is a very young new neo-pagan
weirdo holiday and it is taught like a
sacrament in public schools in this
country and the most important book ever
written is banned from public schools
why is it banned the Bible has been
banned from school since 1963 because of
a very stupid Supreme Court decision
called Abington School District V
Schempp this was part of the very
activists leftist war in court and in
the ensuing decades since 1963 people
have been getting dumber and dumber and
dumber I don't think this is a
coincidence not only is the Bible the
most important book ever written the
Bible is the 73 most important books
ever written
all of them are more important than all
the other books ever written how could
you possibly understand the other things
you're supposed to learn in school
without knowing the Bible speaking of
Hamlet how could you possibly understand
Hamlet without understanding the story
of Cain and Abel or without
understanding purgatory that Hamlet
begins be a spoiler alerts if you have
you haven't read Hamlet got some
spoilers coming he
because King Claudius murders his
brother who's Hamlet's father he murders
his brother and he specifically invokes
the story of Cain and Abel how can you
really appreciate that without knowing
first the story of Cain and Abel from
the book of Genesis
how does Hamlet find out about this this
something rotten in the state of Denmark
how does he find out about this
nefarious act because the ghost of his
father comes to him but you cannot
appreciate that scene of Hamlet talking
to the ghost of his father without
understanding purgatory without
understanding this middle ground between
hell and heaven this area where you get
in you have hope you are going to go to
heaven but you are being punished and
cleansed until you get to heaven the
reason you can't understand it until
that point is because at the time that
Hamlet was written the conception of
purgatory and purgatorial souls is that
the souls could come down to earth you
could maybe see a vision of this spirit
and they would ask you to pray for them
and what's interesting about Hamlet is
that the spirit comes back to earth and
tells Hamlet to get revenge for him so
then Hamlet has in his mind this
question is this the true soul of my
father and purgatory waiting to go up to
heaven or is this a demon an apparition
some some manifestation of madness in my
own mind all of that you would miss if
you don't understand
purgatory how about the Protestant
revolution Hamlet is a play about the
Protestant revolution it is all it is
explicitly about Martin Luther and
Wittenberg and the Protestant revolution
you would miss the essence of the play
what it says about truth what it says
about the church if you don't understand
that all of that will be missing because
you are not allowed to be taught the
Bible in schools you're not allowed to
be taught those theological disputes at
the heart of the Protestant revolution
at the heart of Hamlet how could you
understand forget Hamlet we've been
talking about Hamlet for too long
how would you I guess you could talk
about Hamlet really for days and days
and days because it's so rich the only
way you can't talk about it is if you
don't know the culture that undergirds
it how could you just
the Gettysburg Address Gettysburg
Address a lot shorter than Hamlet very
short text and yet it is not
understandable without the King James
Bible basically all that Abraham Lincoln
ever read was the King James Bible and
Shakespeare the language of the
Gettysburg Address is the language of
the King James Bible that that nation
conceived in Liberty dedicated devotion
the last full measure of devotion all of
this language is coming from the
language of the King James Bible John
Adams second president of United States
says our Constitution was built for a
moral and religious people and it is
wholly unfit to the governance of any
other people how does that Constitution
survive when church membership reaches
all-time lows with religiosity reaches
all-time lows and what ultimately the
cause of all of that when biblical
literacy when religious education hits
all-time lows if your religious
education disappears if your biblical
literacy disappears all of your other
education is going to disappear in the
West it cannot remain because it's the
basis of it how hell on earth
you say listen you can keep your whole
house you can keep your entire beautiful
house we're just going to rip out the
foundation but keep living in your house
it'll be fine what could go wrong say
well I pretty sure I need my foundation
if I'm gonna live in my house now the
Supreme Court Earl Warren said in 1963
you're not allowed to have a foundation
to your house but it should be fine what
would happen in the ensuing decades if
you ripped out the foundation of your
house it would all come tumbling down
and that is what we're seeing happen to
our education and therefore to our
society we've talked a lot about liberal
education because of all those scandals
at the universities all the way from
parents trying to buy their kids way in
to be getting squirted with some weird
chemical at University of Missouri
Kansas City this crisis of liberal
education is a crisis of politic
and culture in the whole country because
you need liberal education in order to
have a free society
the liberal arts mean the arts of
freedom it's the way that we make sense
of our freedom the way that we earn our
freedom if that disappears which it is
we've seen that happening since the 60s
your institutions of Liberty your your
governmental institutions your society
are going to erode along with it how can
we educate people without exposing them
to the most important book ever written
not very well and this brings us to the
bigger question can the West survive a
post-christian Society I don't see how
they can which is why President Trump is
attacked all the time because he's
cheated on his wife and he's been
married multiple times and he says
naughty words and he doesn't seem to go
to church very much they say this guy is
a terrible guy is a terrible Christian
why on earth would Christians vote for
him at least he gets it at least he gets
the existential problem that we're
facing
he might behave in a way totally
contrary to how we hope Christians
should behave he might behave in a way
totally contrary to sainthood maybe he
does I don't know I don't know Donald
Trump maybe does maybe doesn't maybe he
has immense contrition and repentance
and faith maybe he doesn't I don't
really care that's his problem that's a
problem between him and God what I care
about is whether the society can survive
and when that guy a thrice-married
lapsed Presbyterian is calling for Bible
literacy in schools I got to support
that you should support that 2/8
atheists should support that too the
secular the religious or the spiritual
but not religious they should support
that too imagine if someone came out and
said you can read every single book in
school but you you can study everything
in school except you can't study
arithmetic no you can do algebra and
trigonometry and calculus but you just
you can't do arithmetic so why not well
the Supreme Court said in 1963 you can't
do arithmetic
without arithmetic you can't do any of
the other math even if you don't believe
in the Bible even if you don't believe
in the in Christianity even if you don't
believe in the stories certainly we know
that there's a lot of truth value there
certainly we know it's it's the
difference that John Stuart Mill the
philosopher explained between radicals
what we would call leftists today and
conservatives he says the difference is
when you when the radical comes across a
tradition like Jeremy Bentham he looks
at it he says is it true is this
specific story in the Bible literally
true in the way that I'm asking if it's
true and what the conservative says is
like Carlisle is what does it mean what
does the Bible mean what do those
stories mean if we if we don't ask that
question if we don't have the humility
and the seriousness and the wisdom to
ask that question we're not going to
know what any of the other stuff means
either this this is a problem of
Education and it's why I am encouraged I
have to bring this up you know I was in
Missouri I was harassed shouted down
screamed silenced and then eventually
physically assaulted by these weirdos at
the University of Missouri Kansas City
and what happened the next morning there
was a letter from the Chancellor of that
University Molly agrawal not apologizing
to me not condemning the students trying
to use the hecklers veto but actually
condemning me as some sort of bigot with
no evidence no reasoning no argument
just smearing me as a bigot and then
applauding the students who screamed and
shouted and tried to silence the speaker
from the very beginning that man is
unfit to run an American University that
man should be fired he should he should
actually have the integrity to resign
because he is such an abject failure in
his job of running a university he
should have great contrition he should
apologize and he should resign but he's
not doing that he's not going to do that
he's going to continue to
that university into the ground and so
fortunately there's some courageous
Missouri state legislators who are
trying to do his job for him and get him
to resign Missouri state legislator
David Sater said as far as I'm concerned
agrawal can go Missouri state
representative Robert Ross asked the
president of the entire University of
Missouri system President Mun Choi quote
at what point would a staff member not
be worth that trade-off in a reduced
amount to your budget he's threatening
to defund the system cut cut the budget
of the University of Missouri system if
he doesn't fire this absolute disgrace
to higher education
Molly agrawal that's good that's showing
some backbone that's what Republicans
have to do we have to push back hard
we can't just work around the edges and
try to get a few more conservative
professors in there and try to maybe get
a few more teachers and break the public
teacher unions just a little bit no
that's not gonna work you need to talk
tough and you need to back up your talk
with actions you need all the way up to
the president of United States
supporting legislation for Bible
literacy in schools for Bible Literacy
that has been totally destroyed because
of some stupid ridiculous Supreme Court
decision and we need our legislators all
around the country not just in Missouri
not just David Sater and Robert Ross we
need them to go in and say listen you
hacks you leftist thugs who were gutting
out our universities who were hollowing
them out from within and destroying
education in America you've got to go
and if you don't go we're gonna defund
you and those kids can go to some other
school plenty of schools in the country
plenty of colleges in the United States
way too many colleges in the United
States compared to the ones that are
actually fulfilling their mission of
educating students so will defund you
will defund the whole damn school it's
not doing any good anyway all it's doing
is harm in its current form so will
defund you unless you back up the values
of educate
those guys are doing great work I hope
that legislators around the country do
this I hope that I'm a little nervous
for how Cal State is going to react to
my speech tomorrow because the president
of that University is already sending
out advance letters talking about the
awful costs of free speech so I got to
tell you I don't have a whole lot of
confidence that they're going to handle
that well either but bad educators bad
administrators have to go we got to hold
their feet to the fire it seems like a
minor issue because it affects 18 and 22
and 15 year olds and on it so we think
uh we'll focus on bigger issues tax cuts
reforming certain welfare programs now
that big issue is the education that's
that's what could gut the whole society
so we'll see what happens tomorrow in
the meantime I will I'll be subbing in
for Ben on his radio show today so if
you want two more hours of just
unbridled me come on over there in the
meantime I'll see you tomorrow and maybe
I'll see you at Cal State LA
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Noel's show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Jeshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright day Lee Weyer 2019 hey guys
over on the Matt Walsh show today
horrific terror attacks against
Christians and Sri Lanka which I'm sure
you've heard about we're gonna discuss
that we're gonna discuss the persecution
of Christians which is which is
happening on a large scale across the
world and is often ignored in the West
and we'll talk about the fact that
certain prominent Democrats seem to be
going out of their way to avoid
acknowledging that Christians are the
ones being attacked and who were
attacked yesterday also I have been the
subject of a pretty outrageous and
ridiculous smear by a British
publication for comments that I made on
my show about gay adoption so we will
dissect that a little bit and we'll talk
about that as well today over on the
Matt Walsh show